jumpers
[Laughter]
it [ __ ] works man welcome back to the
podcast everybody
we've got a very special episode
explain to us why it's special in
anticipation of uh the episode sweet D
has a heart attack we started thinking
um offline offline offline we started
thinking and talking about the episode
and if we had any ideas on how to spice
it up pepper it up sure and the
suggestion was made that we all get our
blood work done
and that Meg included and that yeah and
that we uh have that blood work analyzed
by professional not just like a bag of
it not just like a plastic bag of it
that you carry around like yeah
not not the blood bucket and we've
discussed that and then we started
getting into the conversation of which
doctor to use and then once we started
15 minutes into that conversation we
realized this should be on the Pod yeah
because everybody's got a different idea
of what a doctor is apparently
so a maybe what we should do
is we should talk about
um whose doctor we think we should use
or if we should find I mean a completely
outside fifth party
who's uh who can remain neutral but but
the overall goal if I'm not mistaken is
to find out who is the most healthiest
who's more healthier
wasn't that the goal yeah
I was bumping on the grammar I did it on
purpose it's a Mac reference
we should get our eyes checked as well
yeah because well
perception issues flexibility I mean
like what are we talking about like what
what's the question like so like what is
health what is well see but this is the
but this is how do we get into mental
health but this is part of the problem
too because because each doctor is going
to have a different view on what numbers
look good right yeah and more
conventional uh sort of doctor is going
to
you know use a different standard than
uh say you know someone who
I don't know has
like more Progressive view on
Health
well here's the thing no it's you can
you can each different doctors can
interpret the information differently
should we go to the type of doctor that
you would want to deal with your health
if you were having an art a heart attack
well you would want to you would want
the most conventional okay you would
want a cardiologist however I would I
would say a very strict Western medicine
cardiologist right but at the same time
it that's reactive as opposed to as
opposed to looking at overall heart
health and projecting forward meaning
traditionally and I'll let you speak to
this because this is more your bag than
anything else is that Western medicine
leans very heavily and not into
preventative care but into reactive care
you come in you have heart problems well
let's just get you on some medication
and then you'll be on that for the rest
of your life there's never a question of
what are you eating and and that really
is kind of true yeah absolutely yeah
that's one of the biggest problems with
it yeah for sure now this is why this is
why I actually like my doctor because he
is a heart specialist that's how he
started he he was a total Western
medicine guy
now I noticed you said he and him and
Guy now are we going to say it's
important I think we can all agree on
this we want it to be a man
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
before we land on the doctor what the
test should be do we have a prediction
for who is the healthiest you know again
it's what is it what does it mean what
do we mean by healthiest
not sick
I can tell you that I'm a very good
cardiovascular shape but my liver is
probably [ __ ]
I think this is it's it's kind of it's
complicated it's complicated right
because
you know as I say like my my doctor he
he started out as a total Western
medicine guy and still studies you know
this is a guy who is in his 70s and
still continues to like read research
papers like he reads oh he's a he even
said to me the other day he's like I
shouldn't have been a doctor I should
have been a a professor I should have
been a teacher
because like he finds the academic side
of the medical profession
um more fascinating than I think
actually practicing medicine and
applying it it's kind of rough you're
like in an in an appointment with him
and he's questioning whether he wants to
be a doctor yeah I don't know if I want
to be here right now yeah yeah I would
have been better at something else
anyway
I had the opposite reaction I was like
that's amazing because like he this is a
guy who literally because like that's
the thing with doctors like sometimes I
feel like at a certain point they don't
they're not up on the most recent
research they're still going on like
what they learned in medical school 30
years ago you know what I mean and and
that's what I like about this guy is
that he's not doing that he's looking
for all the most recent evidence and
research-based stuff about what about
what is to be healthy and how to get
there
because I can tell you that my general
physician is exceptionally Western
medicine how and he does the same thing
except what is the data like what's the
data set that your guy is using that
what my guy is using is clinical trials
and yeah yeah exactly well so so yeah so
my my guy uh my guy uh he specializes
the guy like his whole thing is like the
most recent thing I think as I
understand it and I'm gonna botch this
but like
is that what we're discovering is that
you know the whole like trying to live a
longer life right dealing with like
human longevity is not just about you
know not wanting to die it's the
implication that if you are living
longer
you are you you are by definition
disease more disease free because you
can't live longer if you've got disease
if you're riddled with disease or you
have diseases that are going to cause
you to age disease is what causes you to
age your things start to break down they
stop working as well as it you know so
that's what he specializes in is is
essentially trying to keep your body as
youthful and young as possible
not for aesthetic purposes but for the
purpose of living living longer and more
diseased free don't all doctors try to
keep you disease free isn't that there
isn't that the thing no so that's what
Rob was talking about they don't they
react to when you get a disease yes and
he's trying to get out ahead of saying
hey before you get a disease I think you
should do this so what is his approach
with you uh once a year I go in I get uh
I get gobs of blood taken urine feces
saliva whatever he needs to do just
trying to get the big picture yeah he
wants to he wants to test my you know my
vitamin vitamin and mineral levels he's
testing my hormone levels he's testing
my you know uh there's certain you know
markers that exist for for you know
whether you're aging whether you're your
biological where you
whether you are your biological age
internally or if you're older or younger
you know
that's a good test yeah this is how old
you are this is how old you really are
yeah if this is how old you look what's
the legitimacy of that test though
that's the question you know like yeah
how much of it is well for the sake for
the for the purposes of the podcast it
is 100 Ironclad legitimate
yeah but it could be or it could be uh
there's a look there's a lot of kind of
I can tell pseudoscience that's floating
around sure I think that's fair it's
hard to know
[Laughter]
is it the difference between oh I think
we have to figure out what the then we
have to agree on what those
what the markers would be it would be
the difference between say the SATs or
an IQ test
right where like we're finding more and
more often that that any kind of
standardized testing is just so
subjective and so like based on culture
style of learning a certain style yeah
yeah and and also based on environment
and and understanding you know what
you're playing whereas intelligence
testing is like basically about
processing it's a very it's it's it's
less as as I understand it it's um it's
less based on subjective but definitely
haven't they now because it used to be
thought that you could not increase your
IQ and haven't they recently learned
that that's actually not true you can
actually improve upon your IQ don't know
I suppose if it's just a test with a
score
theoretically why couldn't you
approve upon that you know because well
this the the as as I think I just said
approve which means I would do very
poorly on it we don't know enough yeah
how do we improve upon this
how do I make well there's the doctor
that you have to pick to analyze the
results but also we could talk about
what kind of phlebotomist do you like
meaning the person who's actually taking
the blood what style did you like of
that because I have a real needle phobia
and I've had a nurse one time think that
it would be like better for me if they
say I'm gonna do it on the count of
three and then do it on one I don't like
that you don't like that I don't like
that move we're building trust here
you've got a needle you're about to
stick in my body I think the style of
phlebotomist is probably easy for all of
us because it's pretty standard which is
um skinny Way's big tits
yeah and then the assumption is there
that she can actually do her job but
that's that's not your hair well yeah
she went to nursing school yeah nursing
school she did the whole thing but
she also yeah it's Los Angeles I bet I
can find that for you oh yeah a week of
five of course have you ever seen those
Billboards that are for um medical
marijuana doctors now they don't have
them anymore because it's legal in L.A
but um there was one for a while that
had just like a really pretty uh woman
on it and it would say actual doctor
like that was part of the selling was
like not only do you get a weed
prescription but a hot lady is going to
give it to you she's a doctor don't
worry actually yeah yeah if you can
believe it this person if you can
believe this yeah
um I mean if there's
it'd be fun to do it in a way that it's
not going to be too vague right to get
something that's what I'm saying like we
have to agree on whatever that is and
then it's Ironclad well we could we
could we could excise some of the more
controversial
um you know elements of it right some of
the stuff that's a little bit
newer and less time tested you know what
I mean we could remove some of those
things
um and and kind of stick with the things
that we are pretty provably correct
although science as we have established
is a liar sometimes should it be
relative to our age meaning you know
because Meg and I are significantly
younger than you guys if we were too if
we were to compare well I think to
compare our numbers to theirs because
they're in a different age it's also
you know what I have to say like I'm I
was thinking about this and getting just
a little bit of anxiety because this is
a contest that I want to win yes there's
a number of reasons for that but the
main reason isn't because I want to beat
you guys or anything like that it's that
I have poured so much time and energy
into being as healthy as I possibly can
if you don't win that's gonna wreck
that's gonna work but the thing that
[ __ ] me up is that over the the course
of this summer basically for the last
like two or three months
I just have I have purposely I've gotten
so tired of eating super healthy that
I've just kind of gone well what if I
just kind of do a little bit more of
just eating whatever I want so for the
last like two or three months I've been
eating somewhat healthy but kind of
eating whatever the [ __ ] I want like
enjoying your life a little bit enjoying
my life a little bit more and not being
so where does that go into the health
yeah well so that's my concern I feel
like that's gonna [ __ ] with my numbers
and I'm like I just spent the last time
I don't think it is maybe not what if it
doesn't and then you find out you could
have been eating that way the whole time
and it wouldn't have affected well or
that or that it's it's only because it's
only been going on for two or three
years yeah yeah there's a balance I mean
there's no arguing that if you only ate
a you know fried food and soda yeah I
don't know three you know meals a day
for your entire life you you want to be
in good health right but I don't you
know there's probably something like if
you're if you're depriving your body of
a certain amount of uh whatever I don't
know enjoyment sugar whatever whatever
it is yeah that you might be unhealthy
in a different way it's hard enough what
do you want to win the most cholesterol
testosterone what would be the thing I
know for a fact that I had to drop in my
testosterone and my doctor was like
40. yeah yeah and my doctor was like you
know this is fine as long as every as
long as you're still functioning and
everything's fine yeah that's right you
know go about your business and so I've
done nothing to corresponded with any
change in like your
do you feel that hormone drop no
difference oh really no no it's great
because it's so gradual maybe yeah right
right right yeah you don't see it
happening yeah or you had so much
despair that it's like yeah that might
be it too yeah right so man manly abuse
it used to be so manly and now you're
just regular man that's a little bit now
you're just very manly chill well I've
enhanced myself
uh just through the you know my diet and
my vitamin intake right uh so there's
that but that's part of it right it's
like what have I been doing to get those
numbers where I want those numbers to be
where my doctor wants those numbers to
be you know so I think that's okay I
think that's fair of course because
that's because that's the state of your
body as it stands right now it doesn't
matter or if we do this in three weeks
you everybody has the opportunity to
clean up for three weeks if they really
want to or I'm thinking about it I'm
considering that's a good motivator but
I feel like that's not what we should I
don't think that that should no we
should we should just be living in
normal lives yes I think we should go
about our business the way we normally
would do what you're doing do your
normal healthy [ __ ] but also do your
normal unhealthy [ __ ] and let's see
where the I mean I wonder if it's just
as simple as like let's just take a
standard blood test and start with that
and what do those numbers mean where are
we at but again like the interpretation
of those numbers right because I've
gotten to I've gotten some of those
blood tests back and my doctor's like
okay
we used to think and the conventional
way of thinking is that this is where
you want to be but what we're now
learning is that you actually want to be
closer to this there have been specific
moments when I'm going through my blood
tests with my doctor where he's like
don't worry about this is a little high
but don't worry about that because we're
discovering that that doesn't really
matter you know yeah it's maybe certain
cholesterol markers and does he
prescribe you like sound baths to get
rid of it or like what's his
prescription well so his whole thing his
whole thing in the face right there you
know yeah
but you know what here's here's what you
know when somebody goes slap I just
trying to roll with it I'm like a blade
of grass you know I'm blowing in the
wind I sway but I don't break I don't
snap
oh blade of grass baby I'm known for
that
what's that it's all the sound it's all
the sound bathing sound bath is awesome
have you ever try it out no I actually
haven't I've never done that all three
of us yeah
they just rub this thing around the rim
of a bowl and it just makes this tone
that sounds lovely but hand me a hand
just give me a handful of pills you know
what I mean but that's interesting that
you're more into this they're not
Pharmaceuticals they're not
Pharmaceuticals they're plant-based
version of the vitamins how far okay how
about this are we good are we going to
do things like eyesight and hearing are
we are we checking to see who the
superior human is is my question I'm
like my hearing is my hearing is but I
have very good eyesight my eyes are
going and your eyes are gone my ears are
your ears are great great yeah and
what's more important would you rather
be able to see
we're here now I don't get sleepy you
know the way you're sleepy a lot yeah
um but [ __ ] hurts you know you don't get
but there's you know for me it's really
that that that afternoon dip that's when
it really gets me but I don't get that
but I don't get that no that's great
pretty good energy all day but
like yes flexibility
that's gonna be rough for all that's
gonna be rough for all of us that's
gonna be rough for all of us
you could probably get lower oh Meg
you're probably we could find out how
low we can go right now that's something
we can do right I can't go low but I
happen to know I have impingements in on
my hips it seems a little unfair so it's
like it's going to is that going to hurt
is that bad for you necessarily unfair
that's just where his body is I know but
is it gonna hurt you to try it no okay
let's see how low we can go now this is
cold
foreign
[Laughter]
I definitely used to I would say that
that used to be true but I don't but
that's not a flexibility that's a
skeletal thing so a lot of that is yeah
a lot of that's what about okay how
about this what about just being able to
touch your toes yeah well I can do that
no problem I think I can do that there
you go
but cold yeah so we could all get there
in 15 minutes let's just try to touch it
right now okay let's try to touch our
toes from a standing position oh crust
all right oh dude you went down fast can
you put your feet together
oh you're grabbing your toes you son of
a [ __ ] oh look at that yeah no problem
no problem
perhaps not on camera do it but I didn't
like it my hamstrings didn't like it no
and I struck but I I like show the
rotation I get oh see that's like yeah
yeah the shoulders
no good all right ready yeah oh yeah
easy peasy easy peas
my shoulders are just [ __ ] man I don't
know if it's it's it are there different
markers for a woman and a man aren't
they they probably are yeah I don't know
yeah see but but look how quickly this
is what's amazing about the body is that
if you just stretch for for five five
minutes yeah you can put your feet yeah
of course and you feel a little better
too the second you sit back in that
chair yeah oh my God you just released I
stretch every single night before I go
to bed I think you should be more
flexible
it doesn't take
it doesn't take well I'm probably better
than I would be if I weren't doing that
but it does it's surprisingly less
cumulative than I would have hoped
in other words like that I have a sort
of end of range
and I think I'd have to work a lot
harder to to increase that that range of
motion but that that's actually
something I really want to start doing
is like like
just I don't know spending more time
like doing mobility exercises because
like my [ __ ] is like getting real tight
as I get older yeah everything's just
tighten it up yeah and I don't like it
man it's getting dry yeah well we can
there's also strength right like I I've
I have taken a dip in my strength
training uh you've stayed up with it and
increased upon it yes but and the
question is walk around like being
strong doesn't really matter
functional like I was at the beach in
Florida and you know there was a guy who
was like
really muscular right but also fat in a
way yeah like you know that look where
he like had a giant belly but it was
also ripped and I was like he's he
hadn't he's not he hasn't started
cutting yet
is he in good health or is he in in bad
that's I don't think it's maybe it's
specific to his personal body like isn't
that part of it too where it's like sure
somebody's body wants to be big but I
think it's I think real thin is like
maybe not good for that guy yeah you may
have a certain natural proclivity
towards size that uh some of us I'm
saying there's like a certain kind of
fat that's healthy to have too like uh
the uh
it's got a term like gray fat or brown
fat or brown fat is it brown fat around
your organs but that's what you don't I
think that's what you don't that's what
you don't want there's a good fat that
they're realizing oh is there I think
they're realizing
we definitely need doctors oh yeah yeah
any doctor any doctor from any part of
town yeah yeah it's gonna be better than
us my joints are getting bad man like
doing like pull-ups the muscles feel
fine but the elbows man like oh my
elbows are bugging you not only if I'm
pulling my body mass up and down over
and over and over again what's what's
giving you problems physically what are
you feeling these days when you work out
is there something that's giving you
problems or the sport that you play
where you're like God damn this knee or
whatever I don't have any of those
lingering issues but I think it's
because I was never an athlete and never
did anything so like how frequently are
you doing the uh the ice bath things uh
the uh yeah the cold plunge the cold
plunge yes I'll do that three times a
week oh yeah so so that could be a part
of that could be keeping your
inflammation also genetics like my dad
still runs five miles a day God has
never had any problems we're small
people that's helpful like I think
around large amounts of weight gravity's
not pulling on you as hard being a
really big person is has its benefits uh
certainly like I think people in society
will take you more seriously at first
and there are there are certain benefits
right to being a great big tall guy but
man I was on a on a little plane from
Dallas to uh Destin Florida you know
like one of those American ones that
have the two seats and the one on the
other and I went to the bathroom and my
head was touching the ceiling yeah I'm
like how the hell is a large guy get
getting in this place yeah he's they
hunch they got it I gotta hunch down
like I've had to work always on pulling
my shoulders back and my posture because
I got tall really early when I was
younger and you didn't you didn't like
it I didn't like it and especially
because the guys hadn't caught up yet so
I was like make me smaller I was curling
my body in all the time so I have to
work on that well what happens if one of
us finds out that we have brain cancer
that's the fear right that why is that
the fear that's the good thing
you don't want to know you don't want to
know
okay that's actually fascinating and I
think there's a part of you that really
is joking on a part of you that really
feels no I know lots of people who who
truly believe that yeah no I I do if I a
freckle that's cancerous yeah go ahead
and chop that off if I have a brain
tumor and I got like a month to live one
way or the other then I'm like I'd
rather just be like well somebody just
told me somebody's telling me a
fascinating story uh yesterday this is
completely and totally anecdotal I admit
but they were saying that they were
reading about something that happened
some story where a doctor
mixed up two patients charts just
completely mixed them up
told the told one of his patients who
was in perfectly good health that they
only had six months to live according to
their chart
told the other person who had six months
to live
that they were in great health and they
had no problems and the [ __ ] guy
apparently who was told that they had
six months to live who was in perfect
health died in six months and the other
guy [ __ ] lived
now that's a great story and it's like
isn't that great it's such a no no let's
stop there it's such a great such a
wonderful
Story I Heard it here how long do you
want to live what do you guys think
you're gonna do do you want to be yeah
Bob's not entirely committed 100 sure
you don't think you're gonna die there's
a chance it's not 100 sure
this corporeal plane will cease to exist
yeah the meat puppet the meat puzzle
seems to exist but I will upload my
Consciousness into some sort of oh so
you're gonna keep the worst part
uh yeah
into a sentient
um computer being yeah whose body uh
just doesn't need a bunch of pills just
needs an oiling every once in a while
like a an application of some sort of a
lubricating thing uh possibly some sort
of a power source and beyond that uh
you'll live forever inside the body of a
an Android who knows that I need a body
at all maybe I just exist in a Mainframe
well we're making the planet completely
inhospitable to to this Corporal form
yeah and eventually we will we gotta go
digital we're gonna have to go we're
gonna have to basically get out of these
analog uh meat leaves yeah do you think
that we will just end up living our
conscience our consciousnesses
will just end up existing uh in the
metaverse I don't know I think that'd be
sweet don't you want to be done unless
you want to just come to an end event I
feel like I'm just getting started oh
really
nobody you peaked buddy yeah
[Music]
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp if you guys don't know better
help it's a great alternative to
traditional in-office therapy because
it's convenient it's accessible it's
affordable and perhaps best of all it's
entirely online yeah that's right no you
can get matched with a therapist after
filling out a very brief survey we do
love a good survey oh we love our
surveys here on the Always Sunny podcast
and this one will help match you with
the right person for whatever it is you
want to talk about yep plus say you
don't get matched with the right person
yeah what happens if you don't get to
the right person you want to switch
therapist guess what you can at any time
yeah it's obviously very important to
find the right person when you're
looking for therapy and I know when I
use Better Health they just help me
become a better Problem Solver which
made it easier for me to stay on track
and accomplish my goals so you when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there it's just that
easy right you got to visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month yeah and just to be
clear that's better help
h-e-l-p-d dot com slash sunny
I did find two women but I go see for my
my yeah not interested I knew you guys
wouldn't be interested in that I like I
love the idea of a woman just in general
the idea okay
[Laughter]
our opinion of who's more attractive oh
sure yeah which is the most best
professional yeah
I think that's totally appropriate we're
asking her whose health is more
attractive why can't we who's who's yeah
if you were gonna let one of us
impregnate you which one would you pick
which one who do you want to take in the
back yeah
exactly yeah I I've actually I have uh
joking aside I've had a number of female
doctors over the years
um and that has never been concerning in
any way but one thing that is concerning
and I think we're now I don't know if
Meg's quite there I know you guys are
there uh we're at the age when you walk
in and you're older than the doctor or
the doctor is your same age
more often way more often that's that's
scary these are supposed to people who
are older than us but then again let's
break that down because you're like well
you're not even good enough at Health
that you haven't even lived as long as I
have well no I think that's more like
knowing your own like lack of expertise
in just things in life to be like this
person is younger than me yes is going
to be an expert on my health and
well-being like uh I'm coming in and
going I'm a [ __ ] but in my in my mind
I'm a young [ __ ] which I'm not but I'm
but in my mind I'm going I I want if you
really think you're not when you you
make that joke a lot about being old or
because I still think I'm young which I
think is not good for my health no I
don't think I myself I'm young and I
feel young but I recognize objectively
that I'm not again it's relative it's
relative yeah yeah but relative to
doctors let's just say in my mind so I'm
walking in and saying I generally don't
love having
anybody of authority around me whether
it's a parent or a boss or I don't enjoy
that but when I go into a doctor's
office I want the doctor to be my mom or
my dad I want them to take care of me I
want them to be in charge because I
don't know anything about medicine or
science or my health and I want to trust
that they got it that's when I walk in
and it's like a 30 year old I'm like oh
[ __ ] you don't got it you don't got it
so the only place that you feel
vulnerable in your life is in the
doctor's office that you need no I feel
vulnerable a lot I feel so then wouldn't
you want authority figures around you to
take care of you it's just one of the
only places where he wants to submit to
someone else's Authority yes oh okay by
virtue of the fact that they have a
tremendous wealth of knowledge that you
do not have yes about the thing that
you're there for you want to be in
control because it's very scary to be
out of control and then the only place
where you're like I would argue there's
probably two places but like you go into
a doctor's office say okay I'll give up
control because I know that I I can't
control this situation right I just
don't have the expertise probably they
also when you're on an airplane you're
like yep you don't freak out on an
airplane you're like I'll give up
control to the pilots or the the yes
however when I see a pilot Who is
younger I actually have the opposite
reaction where I'm like reflexes yeah
I'm like this person this person got
here because here she is like a Top Gun
up here exactly I don't want Leslie
Nielsen exactly I want [ __ ] I don't
want Maverick by the way I want somebody
who's excited to be in that cockpit
because they still love it I'm too
excited but the same thing could be the
same thing could be I think of course
which is like they're so burned out at
this point that they're like whatever
you're gonna die anyway what's the point
you know well how old's your guy he's uh
you know I don't know exactly I want to
say he's in his early 70s oh
my guy you know he's Danny's guy oh yeah
and he's like he's Western
he's pretty much but I mean he's up on
all his reading research and he is uh a
sought after doctor you know he's a big
Hollywood top guys he gets like flown to
other countries by people that are like
I need to see you specifically he's
keeping Danny alive he's doing great
with Danny Danny's Dan isn't good yeah
that's a thing he's looking great we
should consider Dr Kipper he's the best
do you have a doctor yes I think he's
he's great
um he's probably just like middle of the
road very very Western but very up to
date on again all the data that he uses
whenever he references things it's all
like very buttoned up medical papers and
whatnot is this the guy that gave us the
B12 shots at one time no that's a guy
well what's great about him so he's one
of the Hollywood doctors who comes
around and gives us physicals for the
for the creeps and listeners who don't
know this every uh time you run a new
season of a show the insurance company
makes you get physicals and what they'll
do to just save time is they'll send a
doctor to the office or the stage and
they'll just give you a physical those
people are amazing so we found a really
great one and he and at one point
somebody asked for a B12 shot because it
was really like in the height of uh of
flu cold and flu season pre-covered and
he shows up with a like a whole canister
film and he goes I'm just just FYI these
are [ __ ] and he's like this there's
no science to prove that these work but
if you believe that they do and you want
me to there's no downside well no I
don't there's no downside to it thanks a
lot if you want to take it I'm happy to
give it to you but I have to tell you
that there is no science to suggest that
these actually work well isn't there
everybody said load me up doc yeah come
on hit me uh isn't there some uh well
you're here and it looks exciting
something cool Could Happen
um
might get a little hot what okay what if
what if we did this this might be a lot
of extra work but if we had each
individual doctor analyze the results
themselves and and then we see the
difference in doctors oh sure now that's
interesting so basically we get we get
the results and we give them to all the
doctors and we say we say to them look
we know you're busy like saving lives
and stuff
but take time out of your
extraordinarily busy life-saving
schedules now we are in Hollywood this
is what I mean doctors enjoy spreading
the message right of Health maybe
they'll be into it they'll probably also
bill us for the time so that's yeah
absolutely
as they should yeah sure sure they're
providing a service aren't they that
would be fun and then we could have the
doctors on I don't know if my god well I
don't know maybe we could have them on
not together because they might fight
because they might fight for their own
time now that would be amazing our three
doctors all sitting in these chairs
right here arguing arguing about the
results yelling over each other so no
one can understand if we could make that
happen that would be they probably would
have a very calm and collected
it would be boring because doctors
aren't entertainers I don't think it
would be boring to me I'll say that
because I find this stuff fascinating
well we could see if it was boring and
if it was we could cut that cut it or we
could add sound effects or cool things
to Jazz it up
you know when you like slowed down a
frame it's like I think your numbers are
high are high or hot or yeah stuff like
that yeah all those kind of things yeah
it gets engaged we'll have a little
sound effects board you know I mean
that's how you can come up with a
definitely like a top ten list top 10.
most important things like like we can
agree on things like that are just
simply objective right blood pressure
cholesterol heart rate testosterone
levels well it's good that we're all
advocating for our doctors because that
that means that we're all uh you know
feeling pretty confident about the
doctors that we're going to see so I'd
call that a I'd call that a a win
overall okay yeah if I wasn't advocating
for my doctor and I was leaning towards
yours then I'd probably want to switch
doctors so medicine basically a good
thing right you guys have fallen on
medicine
I'm also Pro preventative care it is
fascinating as well and I I'm also Pro
even though I lean towards traditional
Western medicine I'm like but also look
into the other stuff too because I do
think and I have seen examples where
it's worked you know have you done
acupuncture before I have yeah yeah that
didn't do much for me but but the guy
that that I went to for acupuncture did
cure my son of this crazy rash thing he
was having when he was two where his
pediatrician had no clue how to treat it
and and then and then we went to a
dermatologist and they didn't know and
this guy gave him a bunch of herbs to
sort of heal his gut and the rash went
away wow so yeah so I've seen it yeah
baby nevertheless
I have seen it
I have not seen it all nor do I want to
see it all you know what I mean from a
medical sense no thank you no thank you
I don't want to see it all well they're
going to see it all on Friday
um they're going to see everything
inside me and I could bring that in if
you'd like to the the video I want to
see deep inside your body can I come
along I need to I need to get a camera
up there and see what's what you know
what are you saying you want to join you
just make it a two shot yeah two shot
well we have them for coverage can you
get us in a three Glenn we have the same
cocktail to settle down to your guy oh
yeah we got the same butthole guy and we
got the same butthole guy and he says
it's time to go again that's what he's
been doing he's been to every time I go
see him he's like
I mean not that often I'm just saying
every time I do so many women out there
fantasizing about us and here we are
talking about our buttholes and our
butthole doctors God we've been
fantasizing about us absolutely come on
no yeah sure I don't think so I'm going
all salt and pepper you know man I'm so
turned into a silver fox
that's my mindset that's yourself why
are you going so great is it could it be
your health
could be your age I don't know if that's
I don't I don't know if that's related
to health I don't think so yeah I think
it's related to hair it's just genetics
I still got all my hair though so that's
good yeah most of it well you cut most
of it off but I did I just mean it was
you know of course there is that small
part of you that's that you know you're
like I know this doesn't make any sense
but what if it doesn't come back well
you'll find another doctor in Hollywood
and and Beverly Hills and put some hair
in your head yeah yeah I did read a
thing uh talk about in the on the
comments where someone said uh that we
all have hair plugs yeah yeah I love
that oh we do I'm getting I'm get we're
getting a lot of yeah a lot of comments
about how like we're
[Laughter]
I do take a lot of you know supplements
that are supposed to help with like good
skin and hair and all that kind of [ __ ]
so yeah you know maybe it's working I
don't think we I don't think we don't
look like we've had plastic surgery what
the [ __ ] are people talking about
they're joking right I don't know I
don't know people just liked it right
yeah they want to allow you up yeah
that's okay I'm not gonna let them get
to me I'm a blade of grass baby
but Health a lot of Health but how do we
get into brain how do we get it that's
probably the most important help there
is mental health Mental Health
God I wish we could find somebody who
would do that yeah just break us down
yes I would do that that'd be fun like I
wonder if there is like is there like a
quick sort of like you know what I'm
saying like a like a a set of questions
that helps someone determine your sort
of Baseline mental health should we ask
the audience what they want us to do uh
talk to a therapist outside that see
everything just the blood work what are
they
yeah you want it all man
yeah of course they want it all and
blood sucking sons of [ __ ]
[Music]
can't start my day without it I cannot
it it feels like that no I can't do it
you know what I'm actually coming to
terms with the fact that I
never will not take ag1 every morning
are you we addicted to it are we
addicted
we're just very fond of it because it
contains less than one gram of sugar no
GMOs No nasty chemicals or artificial
freaking anything and it's still it take
it it tastes so good we could stop
taking it at any point in time but we
don't want to because our bodies want to
feel like superheroes to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com Sunny okay so go to
athleticqueens.com Sunny and take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
guys let's talk about sex baby
sex should be the best part of your day
when you get to have it that's right
then sex is all about confidence right
fellas yeah look the chewables from
bluetooth.com make sure you're able to
perform your best when and if that time
arises it's an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis but in a chewable form
man gone are the oppressive days of
boner pills that you had to swallow plus
Bluetooth is a fraction of the cost of
those other products so you can get more
bang for your buck literally and because
Bluetooth is an online prescription
service there are no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
it ships right to your door in a
discrete package and here's a special
deal for our listeners okay try
Bluetooth free when you use the promo
code Sunny so you're like oh I might buy
this no you're gonna get it free if you
use the promo code sunny at checkout and
you just pay for five dollar shipping
that's it yeah yeah that's bluetooth.com
promo code Sunny to receive your first
month for free
and now we jump forward two weeks later
just for all the creeps and listeners
out there I'd like to introduce what
we're doing today which is we are
getting our blood drawn for these tests
that were we were talking about to
compare all of our numbers we have Amy
here who is our phlebotomist I've
already mispronounced it phlebotomist
and she'll be taking all of our blood
now we're not doing urine or
feces we are not are we are you prepared
for that
I just peed I just oh you were planning
on taking I didn't know that it's urine
okay okay
same here okay great
um but no feces
we can skip that part Amy what happens
if they refuse to fill out this health
questionnaire I can't force them okay
well there you go but see now that makes
me want to
yeah I kind of I'm kind of with Rob I'm
leaning towards Rob here I I because
yeah I'm curious to know what the
answers are purely based on the numbers
and the well okay so for example number
17 how often do you use your cell phone
while driving excluding hands-free usage
it's an overall health yes and risk risk
assessment assessment and it's very easy
for one way it's a health risk they
don't have a question on here though is
do you work with three men who refuse to
do anything that you ask them to do and
does it cause you which can damage your
health that would potentially raise your
blood pressure which is a metric that
you could test yeah I will say that the
the questions are too antidotal right
they're not scientific enough right so
like no this is your concern right
that's like
uh
nobody can tell me what to do it's my
phlebotomy
all right it's time to draw our blood
now can I ask a question of you guys did
knowing that we were getting our blood
drawn today did anybody clean up their
act at all
and then I decided I decided not to I
was like let's just be honest
I also learned something about myself
and maybe you're you're King in on this
right here Glenn I actually went the
opposite direction and I think it's
because I at first I thought well maybe
I'll clean up for it then I decided no
no I won't do that I want to be honest
yeah and then for some reason I went too
honest yeah the opposite direction
opposite I started drinking more uh and
exercising less yeah
great you guys are going to be healthier
than me I don't know I don't know so
much of it is genetics too like just you
know so much of it also is like what's
Your Gut biome doing yes what's my gut
it's getting bigger are we checking your
are we controlled completely by the
bacteria in our stomach you realize that
right that's what scientists maybe you
[ __ ] sure so that's the bacteria
talking
you love me the bacteria bacteria sorry
don't let them know where to charge well
um our
our phlebotomist I can't say that nurse
can I call you nurse because I can
pronounce that word no yeah so sorry um
Amy
um is also Mike so you guys can ask her
questions uh if you have any uh about uh
this blood draw okay
knowing that we were also have
um
oh you raise your hand first you can go
no no no I'm just excited I'm excited I
just I'm a little confused most of the
time when I get a blood draw I have to
come in fasting
uh I actually haven't eaten today but I
have had so but but I feel like my blood
pressure's gonna be higher or whatever
is the Metro for this because I had
coffee and then I had no food that'll
affect your cholesterol right
whether you've assed it or not yeah
correct it will um it won't but from
what you know the way they've been doing
it lately I've we've been seeing a lot
of doctors making orders without
requiring fasting
um so it's okay showing that it's not
really making too much of a difference
but ah whether you're fasting or not I
would always recommend to fast of course
if they do a lipid panel which is what
he said your cholesterol
um it can raise it up but well what
about if I fast if I've not just fasted
but I've had coffee like just black
coffee you're good that won't affect any
of this numbers on anything the
difference with fasting and nothing by
mouth is when you're fasting okay you
can't have no food or anything like that
you can have all the water you want you
can have coffee tea no cream no sugar no
additives into it nothing by mouth is
exactly what it is just nothing but so
is my score going to be affected would
you say in a positive way for having
being fasted or I think you would get a
more accurate result
I think what we're looking for is and I
think we can all agree that it's going
to happen no matter what there's going
to be an asterisk at the end of this
absolutely we're all looking because and
this is what's great if it works out and
we feel great about the number then it
was all that it was it was all done
perfectly right yeah and then and then
if it's not then we can just throw an
asterisk up there and say it's all
flawed okay 100 right great now I just
had a colonoscopy I'm sorry yeah no it's
fine I actually enjoyed it I did I did
enjoy it it was really easy that's
interesting
um it was really fun they made it really
fun really and but well the propofol
that might still be coursing through my
system will that affect my blood how
long ago would you do it four hours ago
wait no just kidding I'm just kidding it
was uh well you can do it
first thing in the morning no you did it
like four like 48 hours ago right and
you get to work yeah it was a couple
days ago it was on Monday yeah it'll be
fine I feel great I think we should just
watch the needle go and I have a weird
thing I don't like to look at it either
I enjoy this is very strange I if I see
it on a movie or a television show I
have to look away but I enjoy watching
the needle go into my own well that's
funny I I yeah I don't like it either
your arm and up your butt you're like
[Laughter]
it's not worth our time
one of us at a time or are you gonna
stick us all and no you gotta do one at
a time
[Laughter]
yeah one at a time must be safe
oh nice yeah actually I mean it does
help the vein
pop right to squeeze something doesn't
it yeah I don't know my phlebotomist
always
one of those stress balls do you have a
dedicated phlebotomist well when I go to
the doctor the phlebotomist at the
doctor's office stop saying phlebotomist
um now um phlebotomy
as as uh as I suspected and you is also
from the Greek words that's right
flabs
[Laughter]
flaps meaning vein and Tome meaning a
cutting
cutting right before I gotta go yeah
these are the panels you guys chose so
yes
look at how many there are someone who
chose these uh we chose them in
conjunction with our doctor Dr Kipper Dr
Kipper
really funny text he's like I've already
decided that you're the healthiest
can I go next
since
is that the first time you've ever heard
someone saying it's my phlebotomy it is
the first time yes
I appreciate it
because it's ridiculous
when I first started doing phlebotomy
one of my patients I had a
I was brand new and I had just stuck the
needle in so the bevel of it was just
right at the tip there but not all the
way in and it just hit it enough to
where the blood just shot a straight
stream straight up in the air oh boy
yeah and that was and the patient was
looking the other way and I was like oh
good nothing
exactly did like big like splattered
blood splatter all on your face exactly
can you make that happen on purpose no I
can't
so all the freaks out there
that's inserted
inserted
um well done great thank you and then we
just gotta pee into cups P into cups
stand on the scale oh okay yeah I'll
take a pea cup you got one oh yes and
now she'll take our blood pressure
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay all right
oh we all have a normal I don't trust
this one I don't know about this machine
you know if the machine works right
after that you know
it looks good to me I don't know why it
means abnormal that's pretty good you're
abnormal [ __ ]
pressure is 159 over 78. that's pretty
good that's abnormally good that's not
bad yeah okay well we've given all our
fluids so we've given almost every one
of our fluids to Amy so the blood bucket
yes yeah thank you for coming Amy and
can you tell us the name of your company
that you're working on absolutely I am
with national phlebotomy provider
Network
um owner is Nathan cron and we really
appreciate you guys choosing us to come
and do this for you thank you very much
thank you
all right you can't wait for the results
foreign
to be continued next week when the
doctor is in can I propose a I don't
know what your format is but
it's chaos and we have the results
we thought like oh this would be a good
opportunity to find out if any of us are
headed towards heart attack country and
get our blood taken and find out what's
going on inside of our bodies and but
most importantly to find out who's the
healthiest so we are this is a
competition
um and I'm just hoping that you're not
biased towards Charlie because he's your
patient tune in next Monday for part two
where we'll find out who's more
healthier
[Music]